I'm your wedding proposal planner so I'm
I'm asking you questions cuz help helps
me brainstorm uhhuh does she like to get
[Music]
roofied and welcome back to careful boys
where we are afraid of everything all
the time and today we're kind of we got
a kind of got a scary topic oh [__]
because the careful boys are going to
decide how we would make Ryan propose to
smack w oh wait you get to decide if
we're in charge of planning your
proposal how we would do it oh how would
the careful boys do it versus Ryan okay
that's interesting all right you know
what I'm
saying I like how Ryan for a second was
like hey you guys don't get to dep pick
for me okay called Defensive almost flip
this [__] yo guys that's cool brainstorm
this I think uh skates are involved
somehow hey that's cool skates are
involved why did you say like that cuz
it's obviously a bad idea
hey D don't say it with such a high
pitched voice to get me excited and then
and then tear me down I actually do like
that that's cool what what so skates and
what there's no idea he just said skates
or involved skates dude yeah yeah I I
didn't want you to think I the actual
idea fleshed out does smack like the
[__] scared out of her no she she
doesn't like that scratch that out the
drawing board she doesn't normally like
that no she like how does she feel about
flash
mobs huh she like viral she actually
does them a lot though does she really
so it's too close to home so we
shouldn't do a flash mob okay is she a
traditional type person like she likes
the the Disney Princess type of no she
doesn't like does she like surprises
everybody likes surprises yeah it
depends what it is I got a traditional
one for you okay all right we need to
she probably misses Australia so you're
going to say honey let's go to Florida
all right we're going to go
Florida closest thing to a Australia
that we got here really and then you're
going to go to a crocodile farm where we
will be waiting closest thing to
Australia right yeah us like we're going
to yeah we're going to be there we're
all going to be in crocodile crocodile
farm we're going to be in crocodile
outfits right and then just so Ryan's
safe we're not going to use real
crocodiles for this but then like as
Ryan's like with um smack at this
crocodile petting zoo yeah he walks out
and he's like oh look and then we're
going to [__] attack him and he's
going to be like oh [__] I got you right
so he's going to [__] us all
up makes me the hero yeah and it makes
him the hero and then she's like oh my
God [__] you saved me like cuz that's
like a real Australian man it's like you
got to [__] up the crocodiles and she's
like wow these crocodiles look like
they're like guys in suit he punches one
I don't know I don't know why is that
crocodile so
buff after all right after he takes us
all out the C has a woo necklace on she
like it's really weird My Hero right she
going to be like my hero like how can I
ever pay you back for saving my life and
you go you can marry me [__] yeah oh I
like the [__] part and then you get on
your knee and then we [__] get up and
bro we got instruments and we start Play
and [__] but it's like New Orleans
Jazz oh sick that's even better oh dude
Ryan like
I like the new or yeah that's cool yeah
yeah see and then when remember when you
said that she doesn't like to be a dam
of distress so this goes against that
yeah you're right you're right it
totally flips makes her be that or what
if we make her save you instead you know
that'd be well cuz she's the Australian
that could [__] us up she kicks our
[__] ass but then she she's just
fighting for her life essentially cuz
she doesn't know what the [__] going
on but we put like put like boomerangs
in her hand so that's the only thing she
can fight with all she knows that is
that these are the weirdest Crocs she's
ever seen and they all have matching
Japanese tattoos on their leg and
they're all laughing under their breath
but we're wearing Crocs so it's kind of
like cool all she knows is that Japan
should have never released that water
from those treatment PL that joke's not
going to hit because we don't upload
videos yeah it's going to hit in four
five months we get them in order it's
going to be so fun okay I'll consider
this one but I feel like beating up a
crocodile is like a part of a Australian
manhood and you got to do it to show her
that you can protect her yeah I think
have you ever done anything to establish
that you can protect her yep I don't
think we've ever had to do anything like
that but how would she know that if a
homeless man tries to bite her you can
protect her that's true I mean if I get
the Croc out of the way that kind of
that's kind of over the homeless thing
so yeah what's a what's a Sentimental
moment between you
guys uh when he told her that he was
just hanging out with other people and
she was like so why are you telling
me maybe you should create that again do
you guys got like a favorite food or
even song or anything you guys Shar yeah
we got lot we got all that stuff what's
your favorite food what's your guys song
do you have a song yeah this a song is a
special oh there's a song yeah it's by
Gregory Porter it's called Lion's song
lion lion yeah lion song what kind of
what kind of what kind of genre is it
it's sort of like um it's kind of like a
blues or like a jazz yeah oh cool it's
really good did you have any Initial
Ideas like kind of roughly in your head
of how you were going to plan it out I
did and then I just kept scaling it back
because everything I could think of was
just too much for me what was one of
ideas that you thought of that you're
like I'mma scratch this uh I don't want
to say cuz I might do it still no no we
got to help him this video is coming out
in like six years we got to help we got
to help him think okay have the marage
I'm trying I'm trying to marriage will
be over by then I'm your wedding
proposal planner so I'm I'm asking you
questions help helps me brainstorm
uh-huh doeses she like to get
roofied Good Start that's like number
one questionnaire question she's never
done any like drugs so I don't know okay
well scratch that off straight Ed no
don't scratch it just do it okay no re
roofy her but like put MDMA in like her
drink so that when he proposed she's
like feeling it
and feeling it what I was thinking do
you think she would enjoy uh going to
sleep and then she wakes up and she's
buried in sand oh how like how buried
just like head
like Scorpion King like your friends
Barry do is that low maintenance enough
for you it's low yeah so far it is she
likes would you think she'll enjoy that
like what how did I get here like you
think she like I think she'd freak out
yeah well what if she looks she freaks
out she looks over it and you're buried
in sand next to ooh I think she would
freak out more but what about Gregory
Porter's playing L that would feel like
she
died what kind of food I think this is
going downhill bar I got she likes her
one of her favorite foods is uh so it's
like uh in Australia they have like hand
roll sushi off of carts all the time and
you know like they would that's
appropriation oh yeah super but it's
it's got stuff like teriyaki chicken
like it's like [__] I like that but
that's one of her favorite she likes
teriyaki chicken Sushi yeah she go to
Hawaii LoveIt yeah it's it's like it's
like Surfer food it's like you just grab
it it's good oh cool I got I got another
the original one all right um he's like
so she likes Hawaii let's take her to
Florida no no it's even better it's even
better okay we'll be in Tampa
okay Mexico everyone's going to Tulum
these days right take her to so take her
to Tulum will be Mexican and then oh
that's good we do Mexican
face the cartel Mexican cartel I'm
selling yeah we're the cartel and then
don't you think we're going to get
killed yeah we're going to kidnap her
and then lot of kidnapping you have to
rescue her there's a lot of rescuing
involved I like that my thing was should
not make it about me and I'm always
rescuing her no it's got to go the other
we got to kidnap him and leave her notes
kidnapp leave her clues that she has to
go on a [__] adventure to go save but
what I'm scared is that he knows that
we're behind it so he's not going to
hurt us but she's going to kill us she
kill us and not I actually think the
second she gets a clue from us she's
going to realized it's a game are you
sure I'm pretty sure we're not that good
we cut his hair if we cut his hair and
then leave it and she's going to be like
that's cool one she's not going to know
she's a hard she how about this she's a
hard person to trick with high
production cuz she's always on set she
sees right through all oh I have an idea
here we go this might be the most [__]
thing I've ever said in my all right we
a lot of those brand with me then say
that every day you two are going to go
back to Australia yeah go back where you
came from okay and because you know her
so because you know her so well yeah you
deported all of the major traumas she's
had in her life you're going to plan out
like a little Easter egg hunt but in
each in each in each one of those you're
going to you guys are going to reenact
the scene how it should have been so it
feels good oh no oh good so let's do the
next one let's do the next one no that's
good like let's say if someone's stole
her bike you get her the bike she always
wanted or whatever and then there's
their bike her her kid bike like all the
all her childhood traumas you heal all
of them you heal all of them that's
really good so like so so like but then
that also shows that also shows you've
been listening to all the conversations
that you've ever had like you've never
let a drop of sentiment fall to the
ground hey Ryan how come you're not
writing this down I don't think he likes
you got her the bite I was I think he
loves it that is a good idea cuz now you
have whole life presented to her in like
the healed way and you canot have a you
know you know how sometimes like you go
to a flea market and like you get some
sweater and has a bunch of
problems what you're you're getting
you're basically fixing all that so that
once you're marrying her you're not
getting all you're not getting all these
problems
coming plan about the stolen bike you
already got you one hey we healed all
this during your [__] wedding video
why the [__] are you still crying about
this [__] get over it when you buy a car
do you want it arrived like fixed right
you don't want it you don't want to fix
it after you buy
it fix I want to have a bunch of
problems what do you think about that
idea I think it's good it's just like
I'm stuck on how to reenact the so if
her bike was stolen right what you do is
you buy her the bike she's riding it you
push her off and you [__] Jack the
bike and then you turn around you go but
at least it's from someone you love
yeah and then you kiss her oh no that's
saved it you think the worst trauma she
had is her bike getting stolen that's
exactly where my mind went I was like uh
I don't think it's a good idea but Bart
said Bart said that Bart said he said
the bike [__] Bart was throwing that
[__] is your problem dude I was okay
maybe like her her first softball game
you you're no one was there so she plays
softball and you get to sit in the
bleach is like go smack go smack smack
and just like one one person came that
is really cute he check this out check
this out I got one okay you know how
smack does the hydraulic press vide
uhhuh all right so you go hey babe like
I got let's let's do this video let's
get smashed together yeah yeah let's I
have an idea for the hydrulic Press
right and it'll be a ring dude yeah and
it's get smashed you smash it and then
she cries yeah no you don't smash it you
just set it up like you were going to
okay and then as she's like all right
she's trying to think about like hey how
how what is this going to look like when
we smash it so I could recreate in a
dance then you get get down on one knee
dude then you're like this you're like
hey all along you thought I was going to
smash it oh but this is for you and then
she's like well now I don't have a
[__] video for next week I don't have
a [__] video for next week what the
[__] am I going to do she's that kind of
Creator what am I going to do now I
don't have know have an upload dude it's
funny if I just put the ring in the in
the press and as it's going down cuz the
Press is in our place and if I'm just
like yes or no yes or [__] no say it
say it
that's good but you're still dressed
ring yes or [__] no the gun you got
to be dressed up the sticks are high you
give her all tomato yeah that's really
good wearing a ring costume I'm going to
pull my [__] braids out here cuz I
love you so much oh my god dude that
would freak her the [__] and her parents
are there too they're just like crying
they're just like oh my God everything
stress so sweet like oh [__] it would be
so out of left Fields you would just
probably start laughing then the light
start flickering you blow your [__]
head off right the light start
flickering yeah you replace yourself
with a dummy and then you go down your
head's [__] clean off looks like a
watermelon exploded inside your the room
and then she like Mourns the loss of you
and all the things she could have and
then and then after 72
hours you show up with a [__] ring
where she least expect it and you're
already on your knee
yeah and then you blow your head off
again but for real this
time and then two weeks later you're in
the C right she know she'll never ever
ever blow a second
chance she'll say yes so fast dude oh
you got to teach her a
lesson the first thing is just to ensure
she says yes the second
time that's so much work game damn cuz
marriage is about work you think she's a
traditional person where she she would
like if you're on one knee to be honest
like the the the reason why it's hard
for me to figure it out is because she
likes it the less stuff there is oh I
got it the less stuff the less easy
write this down with pen all right you
ready okay go he's like get down on a
knee hold on you don't need to write
this it's very
easy it's a Thursday make sure explain
it please okay you have a ring in your
back pocket M have your shoe
untie right shut the [__] up yeah and
then she goes honey your shoes untie his
shoe doesn't have laces no but get a
shoes that have laces she goes your
shoes untied and you're like a and then
you go down and then you pull out the
ring and then you're on one knee and
then she's like oh my God and you're
like yep you know what time it is but
it's an empty box and then she turns
around and there's a hydraulic press
right there with a ring in
it I'm want to [__] do it make your
coal make the [__] go that's two
grand that's two grand that's too big
lights lights flash bed go clean off the
room a watermelon [__] flies and
she's like I should have known when I
saw your new
shoes you normally don't have laces you
never use laces never uses laces
something simple when you say when you
say less what do you mean by less like
less actions less everything less
everything she's not a she's like a
minimalist in terms of how about how
about like you just bring a ring home be
like hey you like that she
like hey you like that you throw it on
her belly while she's watching TV like
hey yeah you like
that what do you think that's I mean
that's as chill as it gets yeah that you
like that pretty chill maybe do the the
ring wine glass thing where she looks at
the bottom of it and then she sees the
ring and she looks up and you got a
gun
make the call yeah yeah yeah or or you
do russan roulette and you're just
firing it off until the
one I know there's bullets in here
somewhere you unload the clip you don't
think I'll [__] do it do it I know
there's a bullet in here
somewhere I loaded one of these
clips click click click that's more
simple and more she's also never seen me
act like that even
ironically like it would be so confus
spre suicide as a joke yeah yeah start
playing around now so when it when it
happen oh yeah I'll start planting seeds
I'll just be like you want to eat
McDonald's
or it's a bit this is weird thing that
Ryan's doing he's threatening Su just
little by little like tiny little things
you're going to Australia with her right
yeah so you go to those carts M you know
kak roll you want ter terak roll C right
yeah yeah yeah yeah plan ahead mhm M
with the Teriyaki roll man okay to put a
ring through the roll uhhuh and make the
roll with the ring like it's a finger oh
and then when you go can I get one
Teriyaki roll and she goes uh actually I
want a today I want something else you
go no you're going to get the [__]
Teriyaki roll [__] what the [__] you
always get the terak roll what's wrong
with you you're like can I talk to you
for a second and you pulled her aside
you're like get the [__] ter put my
hand around the back of her neck like
hey what the [__] was
that you call out you're going to
embarrass me in a four [__]
country so she gets that she gets a
Teryaki roll right and then she opens it
and she just Easter ring and
[__] does she like big things no oh okay
I mean I
mean good setup good setup big things
dude bar just got just completely noed
he got I'm asking questions I can out
this guy dude cuz I was like what cuz
what if you like what if you got a ring
that was like this big ooh that's a big
what do you as a costume so you wear cuz
the r and the hydraulic
press I think I don't even want to marry
I just want to kill myself I don't know
though honestly out of all the ideas
that was said that was the best one the
hydraulic it's just the idea of
proposing while doing that [__] it's we
just like that it's high steak yeah yeah
yeah and I think she'll love that yeah
it's like a ticking time on and
sometimes Deion making isn't as fast so
it expedites it oh I know that's true I
would say that's not a bad point
honestly you feed the ring to your bunny
right and the bunny's going to get
stomach ache so then you go rush to the
hospital [__] x-ray the bunny and
then and then she's going to see a ring
and you going be like would you marry me
oh and then the bunny shits the ring out
and then then you give it to her that
Bunny's definitely not going to [__] the
ring out that's high risk right there
dude that budd's not going to survive
hey if steo could stick a [__] race
car up his butthole the bunny could who
who steo he stuck a race car up his enti
like Ste what did you do nasty boy no no
no steo stuck an entire race car up his
butthole and you went to the doctor he
goes my stomach hurts and then x-ray it
there was like a race car yeah I hope
you wrote all of that down I think I
yeah I think I mentally K's deleting
this video you have this video at least
yeah at least I have this it's run by
smack I think maybe like a nice
combination of all of these she might
appreciate no don't do it certain
elements from different things
definitely this be in there she likes
Simplicity right she likes what
Simplicity yeah that's that's the main
part that I'm having I just throw it at
her there just do like a little sampler
box of what we just gave you just like
pick pick and combination of everything
Gators kangaroos so keep the Gators keep
the gun to my head keep the giant ring
as a diversion oo I have the best one
okay here it goes last one oh video's
over
Dude you unzip your pets okay you you
pull out your penis you pull back the
four skin and the ring is on the dick
that's dumb he doesn't have four skin I
don't have four skin God Dam you got to
put it back on then put it back on put
it back on a couple months before
otherwise she'll immediately know you to
build it up your dick is a ring case
she's
like he's got four skin put on his he's
like hey babe I decid to get my for skin
she's literally going to say whose dick
is this I'll be your dick double she I
don't want to touch the ring now no he
just has me in a suit and then he's like
check this out check this out baby I'm
just standing there like that she's like
why is your dick so sad your dick looks
like he's been through a lot with a
Little Help From My friend Joe he comes
in in a bow tie no it's just for his
dick and and then he can go Okay cool so
there's a there's a black blanket over
him with a hole cut out yeah oh dude
yeah see it's hard it's hard every time
I think about it I end up going the same
route as you guys these are all
brilliant ideas you want it to be simple
I'm I'm always for the
roofing what was your playing with the
rofy I don't know I'm just trying to to
have her be ruied and then wake up in
the sand oh yeah that's right that's
right she looks around she sees me
buried next to her and then somehow I
say will you marry me and there's Gary
Porter and you have the the the Ring of
your teeth like this yeah and I have it
as a like the piercing through the gums
in the middle the fact that we can sell
ads against the show blows my
[__]
speaking of blowing on your [__] mind
I'm going to do
[Music]
it